c'est une position stratégique à la
frontière de l'Irak et de la province
semi autonome du Kurdistan le poste
d'observation est encore essentiel pour
contrer les cellules dormantes de l'État
islamique mais ce ne sont pas ceux qui
restent du groupe terroriste qui sont
responsables de la destruction totale de
cette base fortifiée
ce commandant
c'était le 28 septembre dernier
les premiers drone iraniens ont frappé
puis des tirs de missiles en suivi
à temps il a été blessé à la jambe et à
la main mais la plus profonde de ses
blessures c'est en lui qu'il la porte 9
de ses collègues sont morts ce jour-là
pour moi pâtisserie
je ne peux pas me résoudre à dire qu'ils
sont des martyrs maintenant nous étions
ensemble tous les jours
en Iran le gouvernement accuse les
milices armées kurdiranienne installées
en Irak comme celle du Parti de la
liberté du Kurdistan d'avoir commenté
l'expression de colère dans les rues des
régions majoritairement Kurdes
une accusation qui ne surprend pas le
général Yas d'empana mais s'il soutient
son peuple il appelle au changement de
régime il nie toute forme d'aide
militaire ou soulèvement populaire
si on attaque les nôtres qui sont tués
qu'on leur tire dessus dit-il c'est
notre devoir de les soutenir leur
demandons de rejeter cette dictature et
ce génocide mais des combats armés
s'annon ce n'est pas la solution
reproche au Kurdistan irakien des
bergers quelques 3000 combattants kurde
d'origine iranienne des terroristes à
combattre pour Téhéran
un discours qui vise à détourner
l'attention de ce qui se passe chez eux
croit le général et
toujours ses problèmes sur les pays
voisins et d'autres pays qui disent que
ce sont les États-Unis le Canada le
Royaume-Uni Israël les pays arabes
dit-il
le général n'est pas prêt à prendre les
armes contre l'armée iranienne mais il
demande l'aide militaire de la
communauté internationale tous ces
soldats étaient au première ligne de la
lutte contre le groupe état islamique au
sein de la coalition internationale
aujourd'hui il se demande amer où sont
passés leurs alliés
personne de la coalition n'est venu
déplore-t-il mais l'espace aérien ici il
est acquis à l'Iran ou à la coalition
internationale
une question qui trahit l'amertume de ce
qu'il y a quelques années à peine
pouvait compter sur la présence de
soldats étrangers comme des Canadiens
sur cette même base militaire
sont ailleurs déploctiles l'invasion de
l'Ukraine par la Russie accapare la
tension de la communauté internationale
ce serait une erreur dit le commandant
de croire que l'Iran n'y joue pas là
aussi un rôle clé de déstabilisation un
message qu'il répète depuis longtemps
dans la région dit-il mais vous n'avez
pas écouté maintenant que les drones
Iraniens sont en Ukraine vous réalisez
que l'Iran est une grande menace si
l'Iran n'est pas frappé et arrêté chez
lui il ira dans d'autres pays encore
les attaques de Téhéran en soliraquin
ont fait au moins 17 morts et une
cinquantaine de blessés depuis septembre
dernier depuis la France qui se
maintient partout en Iran
en ça ils ne sont pas différents de
leurs compatriotes en Iran
malgré l'uniforme les armes et la
distance ici marie-eveda Radio-Canada au
Kurdistan irakien
[Musique]